In this video,
we'll briefly overview some concepts
that we often see in the literature on
conditional random fields.
That is the concept of factor,
a sufficient statistics and uh,
the specific case of a linear
conditional random fields.
Now, if you look at the literature
and conditional random fields, uh,
often you'll find that uh, the, uh,
different CRF models that
are being developed, uh,
will be written in the form
that's a bit different. So one,
a more standard format you'll see
in the literature is as follows,
I will just write p of y given x as
being one over a normalization constant.
So again,
we have our partition function here,
but times the product of
some factors index by F,
which uh,
so we called them factors up.
Sometimes we call them also
compatible with the functions that uh,
look at, uh, part of the, uh,
target why and the input sequence X.
And I'll put a value that is not negative.
So between zero and infinity and the
job of each factor or each compatibility
function is to look at a particular part
of why an ex and determine whether it
likes it or not.
Whether it prefers that these
parts of why an x take the value,
uh,
that's why an XR currently taking or not.
So we see that if this factor is,
uh,
for instance smaller than
ones are between zero and one,
then this will essentially decreased
the value of the old expression.
Whereas if it was greater than one,
that would actually increase it.
And so I'll just generally speaking,
the bigger the compatibly function or
factors output is then the more likely,
uh,
seeing why associated with the input
x is going to be in this model.
And if very frequent parameterization
of these factors or compatibility
functions in the literature is to use a
log linear form that is the exponential
of a Lennar some that combines
the model's parameters.
Uh, no, no.
That data as a thera here with a bunch
of features or sometimes we call them
sufficient statistics,
they're called sufficient statistics.
Because if you had a large data
set where we have a first label,
why one associated with an input
sequence x one and then we'd,
so we'd have one pair and then we have
another pair of why to associated with
its input sequence x two and so on.
So if you were to compute a,
in this model,
what is the probability of
seeing all of these sequences,
y one and x and y two and so on,
associated with the sequences,
uh,
x one x two and so on.
Then assuming each pairs are a,
each example is independent.
That would be the product of the P of
XD given a whitey given [inaudible].
So it'd be the product
of these expressions.
Now if we pair it dries are
factors in the non log linear way.
So as the exponential of a, some of
parameters multiplied by some features.
Then so this would get a product of a
bunch of exponentiate it sums so we could
accumulate them all because the product
of exponentials, the exponential of sons.
So we essentially get an expression where
we have parameters multiplied by the
sum of these terms. Over
the whole data set. And uh,
so in other words,
the probability of the whole data set
could be essentially written down as an
expression that only depends on the,
some of these features or
sufficient statistics, uh,
over the whole dataset. And
in fact, uh, technically, uh,
we will say that the sufficient
statistics is actually the,
some of the features and
not the feature themselves.
So I'm going over this very
quickly. You can, uh, look at, uh,
the literature to, uh, learn more
about what a sufficient statistic mean,
but just know that normally when we talk
about sufficiency statistics in a CRF
conditional random fields,
they're essentially the features that
are being multiplied by the parameters of
the model.
And then in this case,
the whole probabilities going to be
the exponential of linear expression,
linear with respect to the parameters.
So they're going to curse fun if
we use this parameterization, uh,
they're going to essentially current
respond to a log linear model in the
features that we've chosen.
So if we are to write our,
uh,
use our notation and put it back
in that form that we just seen,
uh, then the conditional
random fields factors, uh,
so the Psi F, uh, would be as follows.
So there'd be four types of factors.
So this is for the specific
case where we have, uh,
a context window of radius one, and we
have a neural network that maps, uh,
either the left or the middle,
the right part to, uh, the,
uh, current position. So we
have three neural networks.
So in this case we'd have,
uh, three urinary factors.
So these five F's,
there'd be some that would look at the
current label and compare it that would
compare it with the,
uh, input on the left.
There'd be some factors that could look
at their current level and look at the,
uh,
input that's at the same position and
others that look at their current label,
but look at the input at
the position on the right.
And then we'd also have pairwise factors
that just look at adjacent labels and
they would correspond to
the exponential of, uh,
they essentially to take this form, the
exponential of the pre activation value,
uh, computed based on the
input on the left for the,
uh, value of the Kia
label in my sequence. Why?
So this would be for,
for this factor,
he would be the exponentiate it
be activation function of x gay,
uh, for the label Ika, uh, and so on.
So we now see that in this notation
where we decompose p of y given x as a
product of factors.
Then the a terms as well as the,
uh, pairwise Matrix v, uh,
really do correspond to the exponential
of a log factors essentially.
So this is where the luck factor,
uh, uh, expression comes from.
Unfortunately, in this form,
there's no simple expression, uh,
for the sufficient statistics that is
we can't ride these terms as just a,
some of parameters time,
some, uh, simple, uh,
deterministic features
extracted from x and y.
Okay.
And that's,
so that's because essentially these
expressions here with hidden units are
essentially non linear.
If you look at the specific case of a
linear conditional random fields in here,
linear is,
uh,
refers to the parametrization
and it doesn't refer to
the linear chain structure
of the interaction between,
uh, the pair pairwise. Uh,
so the adjacent labels. So linner
means essentially that, uh,
the, uh, neural network
has no hidden units.
So the p activation is a
linear function of the input.
Well in this case we can
write the expression for uh,
yeah,
we can sort of further exploit the a and
they have a more precise expression for
a d a p of y given x in a,
as a product of factors.
So we'd have g five now, uh,
types of factors. We have factors.
You're near your factories that a look
at whether the label takes a particular
value.
And if it does,
then we just take the exponential
of bias at the output layer. Uh,
we'd have factors again that
look at the current, uh,
label and that looks at some given input,
the input at the position on the left.
And it would just take whether a dn dicker
to function of whether why Kate takes
of labels c and multiply that by the IFM
puts for the input vector position came
minus one.
And that would be multiply by the entry
in the Matrix that connects the left
input with the current position.
It would look at the entry c and the uh,
so the row C and d column.
So we have a bunch of factors
like this for each class,
potential class C, each potential
position in the input vectors.
I N uh, each position, Kay. Uh,
so this gay and this case,
each value for that key in the sequence,
but have also a bunch of
other factors that, uh,
would do the same but for the input gay
at the same position or another for the
[inaudible] position.
Cape last one. So, um, uh,
so that's for the case where again,
we have neural nets that uh,
we have three different neural
nets in the context window,
but turns out we could essentially
get a very similar expression if a we
considered the case where we think of
it that's just there being one neural
network that connects a full context
window directly to the label.
And that's because there are no
hidden units in the linear CRF.
So we could essentially get the similar
expression and a similarly the, uh,
factors,
uh,
pairwise factors would be the exponential
of VCC prime if y gay a is equal to c
and if y k plus one is equal to c prime.
So we have such factors in the expression,
uh,
for each value of c c prime
and for each position came.
So this would be, we could
write this down as a, uh,
in the expression that is the product
of all of these types of factors for all
values of y c and K
for, uh, a pair of, uh,
uh, uh, sequence label. Why an X.
And notice that in this expression
now I written down the full model as
a product of sufficient statistics or
features times a scalar parameter.
Okay.
So, uh, now the,
the notation seems more complicated in
this form and this is just to make the
mapping with the case where I have,
uh,
factors that are a lug linear.
And if you remember in my expression
the parameters that are f s there were,
there were scalar parameters. So that's
why I get some, uh, fairly, uh, you know,
the annotation for the sufficient
statistics is a bit more complicated.
So in the case of a linear CRF or
so, for instance, in this case,
a linear linear chain Crf,
uh,
I can actually write down the,
into the standard form we saw in the
beginning of this video where I can
separate out my parameters and my
sufficient statistics in this way.
So we have a log linear model and, uh, um,
and where all the parameters are scalers
and they're multiply by sufficient
statistics. So, um, you know, I invite
you to look more at the literature.
If you want more details on this, I'm
going fairly quickly over this, but, uh,
I just wanted to mention it. If you ever
see the notion of sufficient statistics,
essentially we were talking about a,
usually a log linear model where we've
defined a bunch of statistics that we
think are useful for predicting the label.